- Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show,"
ladies and gentlemen.
Thank you for being here.
Thank you for watching at home.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, guys, after
seven months of negotiations,
late Friday night,
the House finally passed
President Biden's
infrastructure deal.
Yeah. So that's
obviously -- Yeah.
So, obviously --
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's probably what everyone
was talking about this weekend.
- Big Bird is causing a stir.
- Big bird announced he was
getting vaccinated
against COVID.
- Big Bird got his COVID shot
over the weekend.
- Big Bird announces
he's been vaccinated.
- Big Bird got the jab.
- Somehow, that was
the big story this weekend --
Big Bird tweeting
that he got vaccinated.
Yep.
It was a big day,
actually, for Big Bird,
because immediately
after getting vaccinated,
he was signed by
the Green Bay Packers.
So that is amazing.
That's amazing to see
that career.
Some more COVID news.
Today, the U.S.
lifted the travel ban on
vaccinated tourists
for more than 30 countries.
Of course, all the airports
are going to be slammed.
Flight attendants were like,
"We're going to need
more duct tape."
That's right -- travelers are
thrilled to be back.
It's the first time people
ever cried tears of joy
at the sight of LaGuardia.
That's right -- New York City is
expecting tens of thousands
of tourists, and they're all
going to walk in front of you.
"Oh, wow."
19 months for a travel ban
is a long time.
Yep, your friend who left to
study abroad in January 2020
actually came back
speaking fluent Italian.
- Oh!
- Well, as I mentioned,
on Friday night,
the House passed Biden's
infrastructure bill.
The bill took forever to pass.
When it was over,
they wrapped Biden in
a foil marathon blanket
and gave him a medal.
They go...
Yeah, only 13 House Republicans
voted for the bill,
while the rest said,
"We think that
if you're driving over
a collapsed bridge,
you can just speed up
and you'll probably make it."
"You guys ever seen
the documentary
'Fast and the Furious?'"
Some business news.
Walmart just announced
that it is now using
fully driverless trucks to
deliver groceries to customers.
- Ooh.
- It's pretty cool, actually.
The driverless trucks
will pick up items from Walmart
and then deliver them right
through your living-room wall.
What?!
- Oh, yeah!
- Yeah.
Walmart is the only place you'll
find cutting-edge technology
and also a barefoot guy
buying margarita mix.
"I'm surprised
it's not more packed here
at 3:00 in the morning."
Hey, I saw that,
guys, restaurants
are facing a shortage because of
supply-chain issues
of takeout containers.
- Ooh!
- Yeah, that will be fun when
the Uber Eats guy is like,
"Here's your fries.
Put it on your lap
or you want it..."
But this is
a huge problem for McDonald's,
because they actually make
McRibs out of
takeout containers.
- Really?
- That's what I heard.
That's what I heard.
I don't know.
Hey, I saw that,
in a recent Instagram post,
Vin Diesel called Dwayne Johnson
his "little brother"
and asked him to return to
the "Fast & Furious" franchise.
Yeah. It turns out Vin Diesel
also left a voicemail
to follow up with him, and we
actually got our hands on it.
- Oh, my gosh!
- You guys want to hear it?
[ Cheers and applause ]
I mean, this is an exclusive.
Let's take a listen. Vin Diesel.
[ Beep ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
- We got the exclusive.
We got it tonight.
Wow.
And, finally, the New York City
Marathon was this weekend.
Congrats to anyone who raced it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Amazing.
I read that one guy ran 17 miles
with an engagement ring
and then proposed to his
girlfriend during the race.
[ Audience "Awws" ]
What's more romantic
than proposing
next to Times Square Elmo
peeing his costume?
You know, that's...
It actually was very cute.
They even celebrated with
tiny paper cups
filled with champagne.
Some big entertainment
news, actually --
the creator of "Squid Game"
announced
that Season 2 is now
in the works.
[ Cheering and applause ]
That‘s right, season 1 left
so many unanswered questions,
like, "I loved this show.
What the hell is wrong with me?"
[ Laughter ]
Even the creator of the "Saw"
franchise is like,
"I‘m not sure how much more
of this we can take."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, all your favorite
characters will be back,
like Player 456
[ Laughter and cheering ]
and...
well, that‘s about it.
Everyone else...
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Speaking indistinctly ]
Yep, "Squid Game" is the most
dangerous game you can play.
Well, other than football
with Aaron Rodgers, but --
[ Laughter, ohs, and applause ]
- Oh.
- Oh, fine.
You huddle with him, okay?
[ Laughter ]
Some more entertainment news --
I read that,
to compete with TikTok,
Netflix is rolling out
a feature called Kids Clips,
which will show short videos
from their library
of children‘s content, yeah.
It‘s Netflix‘s version
of TikTok,
that‘s why, every three seconds,
a message pops up that says,
"Are you still watching?"
[ Laughter ]
Well, this is exciting --
last night,
after 200 days in orbit,
four astronauts splashed down
in the Gulf of Mexico
aboard a SpaceX capsule.
Yep, 200 days in space.
After landing they said,
"We were going a little crazy
up there.
At one point,
we looked out the window
and I swear we saw
William Shatner."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Wild.
- Ooh.
- Of course, this SpaceX mission
made headlines because the
toilet onboard broke
and the astronauts had
to wear diapers.
[ Audience ohs ] So, when
they splashed down, they...
[ Groaning and laughter ]
- Oh!
[ Cheering and applause ]
- Really.
[ Rimshot ]
They really splashed down,
yeah.
Meanwhile, Virgin Galactic
just announced
that it now has
about 700 paying customers
who are waiting to go to space
on its commercial flight.
Of course, since it‘s Virgin,
the first trip will only last
two minutes.
[ Laughter, ohs, and applause ]
The headline
can definitely be improved,
because if you only
look at the photo,
the headline could have been...
That‘s normal
for space exploration.
- It takes a while
to get into space.
- Get this --
customers will soon be able
to earn Bitcoin
every time they dine
at Bubba Gump Shrimp
and the Rainforest Cafe.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Right now, parents are like,
"What‘s Bitcoin?",
while kids are like,
"Who‘s Bubba Gump?"
[ Laughter and applause ]
Hey, I saw that a man
in the UK has found a new way
to help people get around
and make a little extra money
on the side.
Watch this.
- It‘s called the Tank Taxi.
Merlin Batchelor is the guy
behind the wheel.
He bought that vehicle online
and now, requests for rides
in it are rolling in.
- Right now,
Merlin is only licensed
to carry passengers
for weddings and funerals.
[ Laughter ]
- Funerals?
- Or having a wedding.
Like who‘s --
- Or even a wedding.
[ Laughter ]
I love that people are rolling
up to a funeral in a tank like,
"It‘s what Grandpa
would‘ve wanted.
[ Laughter ]
He wasn‘t even in the service.
He just liked
‘Call of Duty,‘ yeah."
[ Laughter ]
Finally, a car parked
on an Italian street
has become a tourist attraction
because it‘s been
in the same spot
for 47 years.
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile,
there‘s a 95-year-old guy
wandering the neighborhood
like, "I know I parked it
here somewhere."
[ Applause ]
Guys, it seems like there‘s so
much going on right now.
The supply chain is still
causing problems.
Paul Rudd was named
"Sexiest Man Alive".
[ Cheers and applause ]
Adele debuted a new song.
[ Cheers ]
And Arby‘s just announced two
French fry flavored vodkas.
[ Laughter ]
There‘s just a lot to go over.
So let‘s just jump in and cover
it all at once.
It‘s time for a "News Smash."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪
First up, the supply chain.
President Biden just met with
several companies
like Walmart, Target, and FedEx
to discuss solutions
and it‘s not looking great.
But, you know
who is looking great?
Paul Rudd.
[ Cheers and applause ]
He was named "People‘s"
Sexiest Man Alive. Good for him.
He‘s universally beloved.
He makes us all laugh.
But if you prefer someone
who‘s universally beloved
and makes us all cry,
there‘s always Adele.
[ Cheers and applause ]
She just debuted a new song
in an Amazon holiday commercial,
and it‘s fantastic.
The song is called "Hold On,"
and it‘s all about
not giving up.
But if you want to give up,
why not try Arby‘s new
French fry vodka.
[ Laughter and applause ]
They‘re releasing two bottles,
and apparently,
they have the same
"flavor profile"
as their curly
and crinkle-cut fries.
[ Laughter ]
I don‘t understand
how that would even work.
Speaking of things I don‘t
understand, the supply chain.
[ Laughter ]
Shipping, trucking, inflation,
all of it has people really
stressed out.
But it‘s going to be okay.
Just take a deep breath,
pour yourself some wine
and listen to Adele.
[ Laughter ]
The new album drops next week.
Her first album was "19,"
loved that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Then "21," loved that.
Then "25," and now "30."
[ Cheers and applause ]
We‘re really -- we‘ve really
seen her grow up over the years.
You know who hasn‘t grown up?
Paul Rudd.
I mean, look at the guy.
[ Laughter and applause ]
He -- he only gets better
with age.
You know what doesn‘t
get better with age?
Arby‘s vodka.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I -- I just don‘t get it.
I mean, from the vodka itself
to the label,
all the way to the bottleneck.
[ Laughter ]
Everything‘s
completely backed up.
So it‘ll affect prices.
And if you order
anything online,
be prepared to "hold on."
[ Laughter ]
In conclusion, what a guy.
Time to cry,
low supply,
just why?
[ Laughter ]
This has been a "News Smash"!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪
Thank you.
Hey, here‘s some COVID news.
Apparently,
the U.S. government
helped Moderna
develop their vaccine.
And now they‘re in
a patent fight
over who deserves credit for it.
Yeah, even crazier, they‘re
going to settle it on a --
with a rap battle on "VERZUZ."
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile,
there‘s also a battle
over the Johnson & Johnson
patent because
nobody wants to
take credit for it.
[ Laughter ]
No, it was the other Johnson.
Some business news.
YouTube just announced that it
is hiding dislike counts
on all videos.
That‘s right.
Now instead of clicking
thumbs down,
people will just write "dislike"
in the comments.
[ Laughter ]
"Not for me."
Yep, no more dislikes.
Instead, YouTube will provide
the user‘s home address
so you can just tell them
in person
how much you hated their video.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, dislikes are annoying.
They‘re right up there with
people who comment "first!"
It‘s like,
"Oh, it‘s just stop."
Well, the holidays
are coming up,
and I read that ‘cause of the
tight labor market,
there‘s actually a shortage
of mall Santas.
[ Audience "aws" ]
Yeah, malls are desperate
to find Santas.
Today, in fact, Macy‘s put out a
bowl of whiskey
outside the store like they were
trying to lure a stray cat.
[ Laughter ]
- Wow.
- Putting a bowl of whiskey
out there.
- For Santas.
Yeah, it‘s hard to recruit
for the job,
because you can‘t just
walk up to people like, "Hey,
you‘re built like Santa Claus.
Do you want to --"
[ Laughter ]
That‘s right.
No mall Santas.
Instead,
it‘ll just be an elf saying,
"Whatever you want, it‘s on
Amazon. Merry Christmas."
[ Laughter ]
Hey, get this,
The Hallmark Channel
is holding a baking contest
and the grand prize is
a walk-on role in a Hallmark
original movie or $5,000.
[ Laughter ]
Even the director of the
Hallmark movie was like,
"Take the money!"
[ Laughter ]
Seriously, for 5 grand, you can
shoot your own hallmark movie.
- Yeah.
- Hey, here‘s good news, the
North American Meat Institute
said it will reach
Paris Agreement
emission targets by 2030.
When I heard,
my first thought was,
"There‘s a North American
Meat Institute?"
[ Laughter ]
Sounds less like a real
organization and more like
something you‘d read
on the shirt of a dude
at CrossFit.
[ Laughter ]
It‘s a long walk
but it‘s worth it.
I like that joke. Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
And finally,
according to new research,
it‘s perfect --
the perfect time to go to bed
for your heart‘s health is
between 10:00 and 11:00 P.M.
Probably explains why NBC ran a
promo today that said,
"Forget your heart and catch an
all-new episode of
‘The Tonight Show.‘"
[ Cheers and applause ]
You guys,
it is Veterans Day,
and, tonight,
our entire audience is made up
of veterans, active military,
and military families.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪
Please, have a seat.
Welcome, welcome,
welcome, welcome.
That‘s right. It‘s just like our
Fleet Week audience but sober.
[ Laughter ]
All kidding aside, I want to say
thank you for your service.
You truly are the bravest.
Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I mean it.
The closest most of us have come
to a war zone is shopping
on Black Friday at TJ Maxx.
[ Laughter ]
"Give that to me!
It‘s not even my size."
Yep, the only people who have
seen more combat than you guys
are flight attendants
on Southwest.
[ Laughter ]
I remember -- I remember telling
my dad that I thought
a life in uniform
might be right for me,
so he went out and got me
a job application for Pizza Hut.
[ Laughter ]
- Oh.
Sadly, they said no.
[ Laughter ]
Of course, the Space Force
couldn‘t be here tonight.
They‘re busy --
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
They‘re busy monitoring
the galaxy for missiles,
aliens, and our newest threat,
bored billionaires.
[ Laughter ]
A lot of restaurants
offered special deals today.
Servicemembers could get a free
bloomin‘ onion at Outback.
[ Cheers ]
Free pancakes at IHOP.
And a free doughnut
at Krispy Kreme.
[ Cheers ]
And if you ate all three,
we have an ambulance outside
standing by, so don‘t worry.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Let‘s get to the news.
The Postmaster General just said
that the U.S. Postal Service
is ready for
the holiday-package rush.
Unfortunately, the holiday
they‘re talking about
is July 4th.
[ Laughter ]
But still, they‘re ready.
That‘s right.
The post office is prepared,
meaning they "prepared" hundreds
of signs that say
"Next window please."
[ Laughter ]
That‘s right. They said that
they‘re ready for the rush.
Although I don‘t know how I feel
about the new slogan,
"United States Postal Service:
We can handle your package."
[ Laughter ]
- Oh.
- You can‘t say that.
- Why would you say that?
- You can‘t say that anymore.
You can‘t --
♪
- Package.
- Some business news.
The tuna lawsuit
against Subway,
the sandwiches, is back.
Yeah, and now, they‘re saying
that the tuna contains chicken,
pork, and cattle DNA.
[ Audience groans ]
Even crazier, when they tested
Subway‘s chicken and pork,
they found it was 100% tuna.
- Really?
[ Laughter ]
- Yep, chicken, pork,
and cattle DNA.
Right now, Subway‘s thinking,
"All things considered,
not bad."
[ Laughter ]
"They‘re all meats, right?"
Yep, Subway‘s like,
"What do you want from us?
It‘s fish served
with an ice-cream scoop.
Come on.
What do you want?"
[ Laughter ]
It‘s not like Morimoto‘s
sharpening his knives
back there, cutting it up.
[ Laughter ]
Well, I read that the CEO
of Royal Caribbean said that
the company is seeing
historically strong bookings
for cruises next summer.
Right now, members of
the Coast Guard and Navy
are looking at each other, like,
"So, you guys gonna handle this,
or should we?"
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, Carnival Cruises
still hasn‘t let people
off the boats from March 2020.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"No, not yet.
Not looking good.
More tuna!"
[ Laughter ]
That‘s right, Royal Caribbean
said it‘s expecting
record profits,
and then the CEO of Imodium
was like, "Same here."
[ Laughter ]
Some --
[ Chuckles ]
Some air -- thank you.
Some airline --
Some airline news.
The FAA has proposed
more than $200,000 in fines
for 10 unruly passengers.
Yeah.
And this is nice.
Starting today,
if you‘re flying from Florida,
they ask if you want
to pre-pay your fine.
- Aww.
[ Laughter ]
- "Hold my -- Hold my Four Loko.
That‘s unbelievable!"
[ Laughter ]
Get this -- I read that
a new survey found that 80%
of Americans use slang words
but only half
know what the slang terms
they use actually mean.
[ Laughter ]
Those aren‘t great numbers,
so I thought
I‘d help everyone brush up
on their slang definitions
with a tiny song.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Tapping ]
♪ Acting extra ♪
means "over the top" ♪
♪ Spill the tea means ♪
you should share the goss ♪
♪ Receipts are proof ♪
♪ If you seem sus, ♪
sus is short for suspicious ♪
♪ Gucci‘s cool ♪
and flex is showing off ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ Curves is when you ignore ♪
a flirty text ♪
♪ No cap means "for real," ♪
"We move" means "yes" ♪
♪ Simping‘s ♪
when you like someone ♪
♪ But do too much for them ♪
♪ And simps are almost stans ♪
but just not -- ♪
Dang! Sorry.
Let me do it one more time.
Can I do it one more time?
Hoo! All right, I‘m close.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, don‘t waste your time
clapping because who knows
how many takes
I got to do this.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Be exhausted.
- Go wash your hands.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You‘ll be asleep by the time --
Oh, here we go.
- My hands are numb.
- All right, here we go.
[ Tapping ]
[ Laughter ]
Oh, yeah.
♪ Acting ♪
[ Taps ]
Oh.
- I thought
I was having a stroke.
I didn‘t know
what was happening.
[ Laughter ]
- Oh.
- I had IHOP pancakes.
I had a Krispy Kreme.
[ Laughter ]
All right, here we go.
[ Tapping ]
♪ Acting extra -- ♪
Nope.
[ Laughter ]
Sorry, bud.
♪ Acting extra -- ♪
Yeah, there you go.
All right, here we go.
Ready?
[ Laughter ]
[ Tapping ]
♪ Acting extra ♪
means over the top ♪
♪ Spill the tea means ♪
you should share the goss ♪
♪ Receipts are proof ♪
♪ If you seem sus, ♪
sus is short for suspicious ♪
♪ Gucci‘s cool, ♪
and flex is showing off ♪
You don‘t have
to be silent, either.
I mean, you can --
[ Laughter ]
Like a funeral, for God‘s sake.
Did someone die?
[ Laughter and applause ]
Jesus.
[ Laughter ]
- I was hearing --
I was hearing tapping from --
I was hearing tapping
from the 10th floor!
- Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Gosh.
You said, "Don‘t clap."
- I did say, "Don‘t clap."
Yeah, I -- Why am I gonna say,
"Don‘t clap"?
- You said no clapping.
- Clap. Do whatever you want.
You didn‘t say laugh.
- I could hear someone
chewing gum, it was so quiet.
[ Laughter and applause ]
And it was off beat, too!
That was the worst part.
[ Laughter ]
- All right,
I‘m gonna get this now.
[ Laughter ]
[ Tapping ]
♪ Acting extra ♪
means over the top ♪
♪ Spill the tea means ♪
you should share the goss ♪
♪ Receipts are proof ♪
♪ If you seem sus, ♪
sus is short for suspicious ♪
♪ Gucci‘s cool, ♪
and flex is showing off ♪
[ Cheers ]
♪ Curve‘s when you ignore ♪
a flirty text ♪
♪ No cap means for real, ♪
"We move" means "yes" ♪
♪ Simping‘s when ♪
you like someone ♪
♪ But do too much for them ♪
♪ And simps are almost stans ♪
but not quite yet ♪
[ Cheers ]
♪ "Slept on" means ♪
something deserves more heat ♪
♪ And if you want to say ♪
woo-hoo say yeet ♪
- Yeet!
- ♪ So now you know ♪
the slang to drop ♪
♪ The next time that you speak ♪
♪ These all will be outdated ♪
by next week ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪
- No, no, no!
[ Cheers and applause ]
- Thank you.
[ Both laugh ]
Thank you very much
for being so patient.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Finally, a man in France
set a world record
for standing
on top of a hot-air balloon
nearly 12,000 feet in the sky.
Check this out.
[ Light laughter ]
- What?
- The only thing more dangerous
is eating the tuna at Subway.
[ Laughter ]
When he came back down, he was
like, "Yeah, still no signal."
Well, guys, everybody‘s
talking about this.
Today, Taylor Swift released
her rerecorded album
"Red (Taylor‘s Version)."
[ Cheering and applause ]
It‘s great.
That‘s right, Taylor
has done the impossible --
she‘s released a variant
that the world
is actually excited about.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Yeah, all of Taylor‘s rereleases
have been huge hits
and everyone‘s taking note.
Today, Johnson & Johnson tried
to relaunch
as Johnson & Johnson
(Johnson‘s Version).
[ Laughter ]
But, speaking
of Johnson & Johnson,
they‘re actually splitting up.
- Ooh.
- In a good way.
But, yeah, they just announced
they‘re breaking
into two separate companies,
the consumer side
and the pharmaceutical side.
Meanwhile, their kids were like,
"Yay, two Christmases!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
People figured they were going
to break up
when Johnson unfollowed
Johnson on Instagram.
[ Laughter ]
That‘s right,
one of the companies
will just focus on products,
like Band-Aids,
Tylenol, and baby powder.
In other words,
one company will just
keep decorating
your grandpa‘s sink.
[ Laughter ]
Some more business news --
due to the labor shortage
this year,
companies across North America
have ordered
a record number of robots.
- Ooh.
- Seems fine inside a warehouse,
but really weird
at your kid‘s daycare.
[ Laughter ] [ Robotically
] Give us the baby.
[ Laughter ]
[ Whirring ]
Sounds like, the next time
you‘re at Applebee‘s,
the hostess will just be a stack
of menus on top of a Roomba.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, the robots
are so lifelike,
they even hit up
their human coworkers
to buy Girl Scout cookies
from the robot kids.
[ Awws and laughter ]
[ Robotically ] It‘s
that time of year again.
[ Laughter ]
Shelley 459 wants to go
to Costa Rica with her friends.
[ Laughter ]
Not saying anything,
but Bob bought 10 boxes.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Anyway.
You do what you can.
[ Laughter ]
Some TV news --
this Sunday, CBS is airing
a two-hour special called
"Adele: One Night Only."
- Ooh.
[ Cheering and applause ]
- I can‘t wait ‘til a friend
calls me in the middle of it.
I‘m like,
"Ju-Just watching football.
Just watching --
Go, Mahomes! Pass it to Gronk."
[ Laughter ]
I‘ll call you later."
- [ Laughs ] -Well,
this is interesting --
I‘ve read that Americans
are ditching knockoff brands
and returning to recognizable,
big-name brands.
- Ooh.
- But I‘m not sure
if I trust this story
because I read about it
in Tim magazine.
[ Laughter ]